ici yannick dumont baron bienvenue à
medica en pologne on est à la frontière
avec l'ukraine ici c'est un des points
névralgiques dans l'aide aux déplacés
vous allez voir pourquoi derrière moi
regardez ici ce sont des dons des
caisses et des caisses de dons des
choses qui ont été donnés par des
entreprises parfois par des particuliers
également ça vient d'un peu partout en
europe de l'eau des vêtements de la
nourriture
on sait que ça vienne un peu partout en
europe parce que on peut lire les
étiquettes c'est parfois en allemand
parfois en anglais en français en
espagnol
énormément de vêtements il ya des jouets
pour enfants aussi l'armée polonaise est
ici pour aider
à sortir tous ces dons qui arrivent là
on est en train justement dvi d une
camionnette ce sont des français qui ont
apporté sa énormément de dons au fonds
en arrière il ya une tentes rouges plein
de vêtements plein de jouets de tous
tous pour les enfants également beaucoup
de matériel qu'il faut trier ensuite le
distribuer pas loin d'ici à des réfugiés
qui continuent d'arriver qui continuent
de sortir de l'ukraine